>> Paulette Hasier:
I'd like to welcome you
to Ninth Annual GIS Day here
at the Library of Congress.
Our theme today is GIS in
K-12, from Data to STEM.
So I hope you all
are ready for really,
really excellent program.
We got speakers from AAG,
Esri, our very own Library
of Congress, and we also
have Congressman Westerman,
who will be here at
approximately 10 o'clock
to talk a little bit about
the Geospatial Data Act
that was just past a
couple of weeks ago.
I want to thank everyone
who is here to support us,
and those who have supported
us from the Geography
and Map staff, the
Library of Congress staff,
and all the folks that I've
mentioned who are going
to be the speakers today.
We do appreciate your
support for GIS Day,
and we appreciate all
that you do to support us.
And without further
ado, I'd like to turn it
over to Dr. John Hessler, who
is our geospatial specialist
in geography and
math, and he's going
to set the stage for
today's activity.
Thank you again, and
have a good GIS Day.
[ Applause ]
>> John Hessler: Thank you,
Paulette, and I'll say, again,
thank you everyone for coming.
As Paulette mentioned, this
is the Ninth Annual GIS Day
at the Library of Congress,
and GIS has come a long,
long way here in
those nine years.
For those not familiar
with it, GIS really started
about 20 years ago here at the
library with a single license
in a single office down in GNM
with a man, Gary Fitzpatrick,
who did a lot of work and a lot
of mapping and tried to kind
of get it all off the ground.
It went through a lot of
different incarnations
to get to where it is today.
Just a few years ago,
it was only a few single
licenses being used
by Congressional
Cartography Project
and some analysts in CRS.
Today, it is the geospatial
hosting environment.
The geospatial hosting
environment is a series
of portals.
We collect terabytes
of geospatial data.
We have hundreds of users,
all of which come from either
across the street, the Senate,
the House members, CRS analysts,
geography and maps,
Congressional Cartography
Project, and even curators
with the new story maps project
that we began publishing
collections and things
like that here in the library.
There are some people
in the crowd
who have been responsible
for this growth.
I see Mike Handy,
retired many years ago,
was part of our IT team here,
who is one of the most
responsible people
for building what is the
geospatial hosting environment
here at the library
and kind of pushing it
through the sixth floor.
We have our engineering
team in the back, Bebe,
who was one of the research
and development heads,
who worked this through during
the last few years, and then,
we have our engineering
team, basically known
as Butch and the Two Mikes.
Yes, and they do have a band,
plays hits from Python and JSON.
And that would be Butch
Lazerac [assumed spelling],
Mike Scholen [assumed spelling],
who sitting back there,
and Mike Bijou, who
was also in the back,
all of whom played a
big role in getting GIS
to where it is in the library.
It's growing.
It's growing rapidly.
Our new chief, Paulette
Hasier, has been responsible
for pushing the cloud-based
online story map program
and moving that forward
at a sort of lightspeed.
We've now published a
whole series of those.
Curators across the
library are using them.
There is training
being done, and so,
the program is moving rapidly.
But if it was just
data and software,
it really wouldn't mean much.
It's more than that.
It's about getting the
staff in the Congress.
It's about getting
the staff in CRS.
It's about getting people
in GNM and curators all
over the library to use their
imagination and creativity.
To understand how to
use these tools in order
to foster what their ideas are,
analysis, looking at things
from a spatial perspective.
And so, today, we're
going to settle on that.
Spatial thinking.
Spatial activity.
What can it tell
us about the world?
What can it tell us
about what we are?
And so, these talks that we're
going to see today are going
to focus on K-12 education,
and it's very important,
because when we think
about GIS, when we think
about where geography has come
as a discipline in the last 20
to 30 years, it's gone
through a revolution,
and that revolution has allowed
the field to begin to think
of things in ways that
it never did before.
It's allowed it to combine
humanistic thinking,
critical thinking, with
scientific analysis.
It's allowed it to come to terms
with things the way human beings
interact with the environment,
the way they interact
with themselves,
with the way we interact with
each other in a spatial way.
It's given us the tools
to begin thinking deeply
about those problems and about
the way we live in society,
and that's an extremely
important thing.
To a certain extent, cartography
has always been about this.
It's always been
about imagination.
about visualization.
It's always been about
spatial thinking.
One can think back to
the second century A.D.
where Ptolemy is sitting
in Alexandria staring
out at the Mediterranean Sea
trying to figure out a way
in order to map the world,
to visualize the world.
We can think of Francois Menard,
the great French cartographer,
who is sitting in his study
in Paris trying to figure
out what can space add to my
analysis of transatlantic trade?
How can I visualize this?
And coming up with
radical ways of doing it.
Or it can be a group of hipsters
sitting in a bar wondering how
in God's name can we map
in three dimensions
the lives of squirrels?
So, it can be a lot of different
things, and all of those things
that I've just said, the
squirrels, the Ptolemy,
and the Menard, if you come to
the open house, you'll be able
to see all of those maps,
because we selected those.
And so, when we start
thinking about what GIS is,
and we start thinking about
how we can influence people
in K-12 education, and I
especially want to thank any
of the teachers who are
here today, because it's
in your hands that this is,
that these developments
are going to be thrust.
The kids coming up
today, the children coming
up today are going to have tools
that can be used for good or,
in fact, for not so good,
and getting them to use them
for good, getting them to
understand the excitement
of doing an analysis that might
squeeze a little bit more food
yield out of the
landscape to feed people,
to help people distribute
limited water resources,
and to understand, well, maybe
even squirrels, is something
that we can start with
very early and very simply.
The data that we now have and
the tools that we now have,
can be brought down to the
level of K-12 students in a way
that we never could before.
The excitement of a child
mapping a squirrel in a park,
interacting with the data, the
computers, and with the world.
It's that triangle that
K-12 builds in students,
and is that triangle that's very
important, and is that triangle
that we're going to
explore in our talks today.
And so, I want to
bring up Tim St. Onge,
who's going to be the host in
the introducer and the master
of ceremonies for the
rest of the conference.
And again, I want to
thank you for coming,
and especially the teachers.
We're here for you.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> Tim St. Onge: All
right, thank you, John.
Good morning everyone.
Thank you for coming.
As John said, my
name is Tim St. Onge.
I'm with the geography and map
division here at the library,
and I'm going to be the
moderator or so this morning,
keeping us on schedule.
So, first, I'm going
to be introducing our first
speaker, who is Kathy Hart.
Kathy is the head
of the Geography
and Map Division's reference
team and reading room here
at the Library of Congress.
She leads a team that
facilitates the use of maps,
atlases, and geographic
materials
in the library's extensive,
worldwide collection of maps.
Throughout her career,
Kathy has promoted the use
and understanding of maps
and geographic information,
as well as delving into spatial
thinking and maps and GIS
in the digital humanities.
She is a recent addition
to the Library of Congress
after spending 20 years
in academic libraries.
So, please welcome Kathy Hart.
[ Applause ]
>> Kathy Hart: All right,
well, happy GIS day.
So, I am here, as you just
heard, I'm here to talk
about spatial thinking,
but before I do that,
I want to talk about maps.
So, when was the last time that
you looked closely at a map?
I mean, it really
dug in and read it
to uncover the meaning behind
the lines, colors, and symbols.
Did it all makes sense?
Did you understand
the intent of the map?
Did you examine the legend
and the text to help you
with the overall
meaning of the map?
Did you understand
the main concepts,
the cartographer's intent?
The same question can asked
regarding digital geographic
maps, or GISs, as well.
Did you move through those
locations, zoom in and out,
understand the layers and
ability to select those layers
that were of most
interest to you?
Okay, so, great.
You are a spatial thinker.
So, I do want to talk
about how you make meaning
from those lines, colors,
and symbols on the
maps and GIS sites.
What happens at the
cognitive level?
And what can we do to
enhance the spatial thinking
and spatial understanding
skills,
including in the schools,
with our K-12 students.
So, why do we care?
Where we talk about this today?
Well, spatial thinking underpins
the whole -- the map reading,
the map interpretation,
map creation.
It helps our K-12 students
succeed in their classes,
as well as their careers.
Spatial thinking correlates with
success in math and science,
and as, therefore, students
with strong spatial thinking
skills are adding advantage
in their coursework and
their later career options.
So, it follows that
instructional resources
for spatial thinking are
critical in the early years.
The good news is that there's
been a great deal of interest
and research on spatial thinking
and enhancing spatial-related
curriculum.
Much of the research
includes a digital component,
including teaching
GIS in schools.
So, what I hope to do my time
this morning is to create
for you the conceptual
connections
between spatial thinking and
map reading and the use of maps
and 3D models and learning GIS
and related digital
environments.
How these can expand a student's
spatial habits of mind,
which then increases spatial
awareness and spatial skills.
Beyond K-12, in our everyday
lives, it's important
to think spatially,
in that it helps us
to be informed citizens.
So, a few fields of
studies and careers.
These should be familiar to you.
There's probably others
that I don't have listed,
but this is just to kind of get
you thinking about the variety.
So many things that are
touched by spatial thinking,
as far as fields of
study and careers.
And I'm sure there's some that
I missed, but you can fill
in the blank on others.
So, the types of spatial
relationships, it's important
to understand the range from
the simple to the more complex,
and it's important when
we're looking at maps in GIS
to use precise terminology.
So, we're talking about, you
know, where things are located,
the distance between two things?
Is there movement?
Where are the boundaries?
Is there a region?
Is something adjacent
to something else?
Is something enclosed or within?
So again, these are terms that
when you're looking at maps
and using GIS, these
are the kinds of things
that you're trying to uncover.
And then, you go into the more
complex spatial relationships.
What are the patterns?
How are things distributed?
Are there dispersion?
Is there clustering involved?
So, as you look at maps in
GIS again, these are the types
of things you're
trying to understand.
At the younger ages, at the very
of the stages, children come
to understand the basic
topological spatial concepts,
such as on, and, with,
close to, next to,
beside, over and inside.
They understand these
just in everyday life
and when they're
learning their vocabulary.
At around 6 to 8 years
old, children progress
to more complex,
projective understanding,
such as in front of, left of,
right of, on the side, behind,
straight, and up the
hill and down the hill.
And this image that you're
looking at here is just kind
of a way to understand
with those concepts mean
when you're looking at a map.
So, were talking
about verbal as well
as visual skills,
spatial skills.
But it's not all work.
There's also play involved.
And while most children pick
up these concepts
naturally, some do struggle.
But it comes, as I mentioned, it
comes informally in daily life,
as part of the acquisition
of vocabulary,
as well as more formally
in classroom activities
and focused curriculum.
But think about the
common toys at this age.
Much of the playtime
involves spatial thinking.
So, you have building blocks.
You have cars and trucks.
You have doll houses,
Legos, and Rubik's Cubes.
These objects can be arranged
and rearranged using the
child's native spatial awareness
and the inborn creativity.
Numerous digital games
also use spatial abilities.
Minecraft is one that comes to
mind, but there are many others.
So, this is all, again, in
the kind of younger ages,
but around grades five and
six, the more abstract,
or the Euclidean understandings
emerge, as does curriculum,
on using a frame of reference,
such as how to measure distances
and direction and using
a coordinate system.
So, how many of you have
seen these maps, right?
So, the children are asked to
make a map of a place they know.
Basically, how you
get from school,
from your home to school?
And so, this is really
good practice,
because some elementary-age
children may have difficulty
understanding maps.
So, practice.
That practice with things they
know is a very important point
for them to kind of
bring that understanding.
So, their drawings, their maps,
typically include their house.
Maybe a curvy line
representing the street
and the school building,
and it's not to scale.
The perspective and the
angle or vantage point is
from an on-the-ground
perspective,
so street view rather than from
above as we know
typical used maps.
The children understand
one key aspect
of map reading and map creation.
That's self-location.
So, the self-location is the
ability to relate where you are
in the real world to
a place on the map,
and they do that by
drawing and viewing it.
So, these two examples
show some fairly complex
and sophisticated
thinking going on.
They also show two
other spatial abilities.
That's route memory
and map rotation.
Route memory is the
ability to remember a way to
and from a place, and map
rotation is the ability
to mentally rotate a map
while you are making turns
without physically
turning a map.
So, you don't have
to raise your hand
if you actually still do
the turning of the map.
It's okay.
We can work on that.
But these two maps illustrate
all these concepts really well,
and you know, kudos to the
students that created these.
Now I don't know the gender of
these two who created these,
and if there's any teachers in
the room, you may have an idea.
May be the one on the left might
be a girl, and maybe the one
on the right might be a boy.
And I want to bring that up,
because there are
some sex differences.
There's studies that show
that males perform better,
slightly better, on
spatial tests such as
with mental rotation tasks and
wayfinding, and explanations
as to the reason for
these differences very,
and some relate to the
environment in the home.
For instance, in one study,
there were no gender
differences found in children
from lower income homes.
However, there were gender
differences found in children
from the middle and
higher-income groups.
So, I will give you a second to
think about why that might be.
So, it may be due to their
home environment, right?
So, I'm happy, though, to report
that whatever differences
there may be due to biology
or individual differences
or economic circumstances,
these are easily
remedied by instruction
and increasing access to
spatial-related activities.
So, my message to parents and
grandparents, give your girls
and kids Legos, building blocks.
Teachers, encourage all
of your students to engage
in spatial play activities in
the classroom, especially those
who may not have the
opportunity at home.
So, moving a little bit more
into the map reading in GIS,
there's a lot of standard
methods that have been developed
over the years, so,
with map design,
and that really helps everyone.
So that when we go
to read something,
we have a common
vocabulary, common language.
And Jacques Bertin developed
frameworks, or visual variables,
as guides to map design,
and these are the concepts,
which I hope you can see in the
back, of position, size, shape,
the value or likeness, the
color or hue, and orientation,
which may be called
direction, and texture,
so as you can see in this chart.
So, these concepts extend to
GIS, as well, and I just point
out Access Map prepared
this particular chart,
and there's a lot of description
on their website, as well.
So, the point is, when you're
reading a map or creating a GIS,
it's important to understand
the theoretical background
and sometimes complexity
to the symbology.
This is just a small part
to a much larger topic.
And I should also point out that
these concepts can be combined.
So, you may have color and shape
that are combined, and you know,
we understand that when
we're looking at maps,
and this applies to
points, lines, and polygons.
So again, these are kind
of the building blocks
to how we put maps together.
And as I mentioned earlier,
the spatial thinking,
it's a combination
of cognitive skills,
comprised of knowing
concepts of space,
using tools of representation
and applying processes
of reasoning.
What we're seeing
now, a recent study,
that suggests a correlation
between thinking spatially
and thinking geographically,
and I will just read off this
section from this article
from Metoyer and Bednarz.
"Geographic thinking
extrapolates beyond spatial
thinking to encompass the
recognition and elaboration
of the relations
amongst spatial concepts,
the advanced associations
derived from these concepts,
and the formal linking
of the associations
into theories and
generalizations."
So, again, spatial thinking
is the building block.
You add the geographic
concepts, and then you get
into the geographic thinking.
So again, maps in GIS.
And when we talk about
geography, you're going
into the geographic
realm, I hope some of you,
if not maybe all of you,
are aware of Tobler's
first law of geography.
Everything is related
to everything else,
but near things are more
related than distant things.
So, think about that.
How does that --
what does that mean?
So, things are nearby.
They're somewhat dependent.
So, you have tree species that
are more similar to the trees
that are in their
neighborhood then maybe trees
across the country or on another
continent, another climate.
Any kind of species,
animals, plants,
but also demographic
and social issues.
There you have similarities
in things that are near.
You have more similarity
to things
that are near, rather
than far away.
So, we can keep that
in mind, also,
when you're looking
at maps in GIS.
What's going on in
that place as compared
to what's going on farther away?
And getting into why, again,
why is geographic
thinking important?
It's important because then
we have the whys of where.
Where things happen is critical
to knowing how and
why they happen.
So, we want to study maps.
GIS, we want to study geographic
concepts and do studies,
because then we will know how
and why things are happening.
We can plan, and we can
do all sorts of analyses
and really understand our
world in a much better way.
So, I want to circle back
to what I mentioned
at the beginning.
We know that spatial thinking
is very important for success
in STEM, and we understand
that skills are based both
on innate abilities, as well
as environmental inputs.
So, it follows that we must look
at the important
role of teachers.
The skills of STEM and
non-STEM teachers are important,
and it's not surprising
that studies have found
that secondary STEM teachers
have strong spatial skills,
as compared to non-STEM teachers
in the general population,
as well as when compared
to preschool
and primary school teachers.
So, what this means is that our
high school chemistry, physics,
and calculus teachers are much
stronger in spatial thinking.
Obviously, that's a good thing.
However, since spatial skill
development is formative
in the primary school
years, we are reliant
on our primary school teachers'
spatial skills to foster
that strong spatial skills
and the younger ages.
Workshops and professional
development
for the primary school
teachers has been shown
to increase their
confidence and abilities
to teach spatial content.
And I will point you to a few
articles, these first two.
Nora Newcombe, who wrote
in American Educator,
really has a great
introduction to this topic.
And then, Learning
to Think Spatially;
GIS as a Support System
in the K-12 Curriculum
from the National
Research Council.
That's a very robust
and in-depth report.
I also encourage
you to read that.
So, I hope by the established
the whys and where fors
of spatial thinking, but
what does this have to do
with libraries, you may ask?
Well, let me tell you.
Librarians are partnering
with K-12 educators
to develop geographic
and spatial curriculum.
I have the third and fourth
articles here are examples
of that.
In Colorado, Theobald
and Vrbancic have engaged
with K-12 educators and school
librarians with great success,
as well as in Florida.
McAuliffe using aerial
photos in the University
of Florida library,
partnered with teachers,
to enhance the national
geography standards,
Geography for Life.
So, libraries are engaged
in information resources
and information literacy
of all formats.
And maps and GIS are among those
reliant on spatial thinking.
So, it's incumbent upon us
to develop geospatial
information literacy programs.
So, stay tuned, as they say.
So, as I wind down,
I will encourage you
to think spatially.
Observe spatial relationships
in your everyday life.
Think critically about maps
and the information
that they convey.
Use precise terminology to
describe spatial phenomenon,
and bring these concepts
into your instruction
and collaborations.
And I want to thank you for
the opportunity to talk,
and I believe, again, we have
more discussion coming up.
I think we're going to hold
questions until the end,
and I do want to put, also,
another plug for the open house
and the Geography and Map
Division from 1 to 3 PM.
All right, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Tim St. Onge: All right,
thank you very much, Kathy.
So, as Kathy mentioned, for the
design of our morning session,
see here -- basically,
we're going to be having
a question session for all
of our speakers at 11:45, so
that the ideas that we have,
basically, a morning's
worth of learning about GIS,
spatial thinking, and that will
bring all that knowledge and,
that will bring all
that knowledge in.
All the questions and thoughts
that are sort of popping
in your head, at 11:45,
we'll have all the speakers
of this morning up, and
we'll be able to answer --
we'll be able to have more of
a cohesive or a full discussion
about all the different topics
that we've been talking
about this morning.
So, thank you again, Kathy.
So, coming up next, we will
be having our keynote speaker,
Congressman Bruce Westerman of
Arkansas, and he will be talking
about the Geospatial Data
Act, Education and Policy.
So, since we are
ahead of schedule,
he will be coming
before too long.
So, in the meantime, we want to
bring up John Wertman from Esri.
He is graciously going
to provide a little bit
of an introduction, a little
bit of the background,
on the Geospatial Data Act,
which will be the subject
of Congressman Westerman's talk.
So, without ado, I'll
bring up John Weortman.
[ Applause ]
>> John Wertman: Well,
thanks very much, Tim.
So, I wanted to give a little
bit of a background to sort
of set the story for
what you're going
to hear from the Congressman.
About five or six years
ago, there was a movement
on the Senate side to put
together a foundational bill
for how Congress and the
federal government deal
with geospatial data.
There was previously a bill
passed called the Data Act,
which dealt with
sort of data broadly,
and I see that the
Congressman is here now.
So, I'll sort of wrap
this up, but essentially,
the bill was enacted as
part of the FAA compromise
that passed a few weeks ago,
and we're delighted to have it
in place, and I'll
turn it over to Tim
to introduce the Congressman.
>> Female: Thanks John.
>> Male: Yeah!
[ Applause ]
>> Tim St. Onge:
Excellent, thank you.
All right, so without
further ado,
I'd like to introduce
our keynote speaker
for this morning.
Congressman Bruce Westerman
representing the fourth district
of Arkansas.
He is a member of the
committee on transportation
and infrastructure and on the
committee on natural resources.
He's an engineer and
forester by trade.
Westerman has worked
for 22 years
at Midsouth Engineering
in Hot Springs.
He was named Engineer of the
Year by the Arkansas Society
of Professional Engineers
in 2013.
So, without further ado, welcome
Congressman Bruce Westerman.
[ Applause ]
>> Congressman Bruce Westerman:
Well, good morning everyone.
I think it's -- yeah,
it's still morning.
One of those days.
This is a good day.
We should all be happy
about what's happened.
It's strange how
Washington DC works.
I've worked on legislation.
I've been in Congress
for four years.
I've got bills that I've
worked on tirelessly
since I've been here, and
worked on this bill very hard.
And all the sudden, we
found a vehicle to get it
in the FAA bill, and like
that, almost, it became law.
So, sometimes as we say in
Arkansas, a blind hog finds
in acorn, and we found
this one on this bill.
And I'm thrilled about that.
You know, at the end of the
day, we want to see results,
and we were able to get results.
And much of that's due to the
support that this group had
for the Geospatial Data Act
and your efforts in really,
not just in lobbying for the
bill and contacting members
and trying to get it
to pass, but the work
that we all did coming to
agreement on what should be
in the bill, and I say
thank you to everyone
who participated in that.
As was mentioned when I was
introduced, my background is
in engineering and forestry.
So, it's two areas
where geospatial data is
used quite extensively,
but I was thinking about
my engineering background,
and I was partner in a
consulting engineering firm,
and you know, we had to have
standards in our business.
Like many businesses that want
to be successful,
it makes good sense.
It makes your business work more
efficiently and more effectively
if you have good standards.
We have standards
and specifications.
We have certain things
that we knew were going
to be purchased many times over.
It wasn't rocket science.
We'd gone through the design.
We'd gone through the analysis,
and we could write standards
and standard specifications.
So that when it came
time to use the services
or these materials again on the
job, that was all taken care of.
And in our drawings,
you know, I'm old enough
that I learned drafting
in college doing it
with -- on a drawing board.
And it's amazing things you
learn when you're doing it
by hand that actually translate
into doing it digitally.
You know, when you're
drawing on paper,
you change your line weight
by using a different pencil.
You do it by the amount
of pressure you put on it,
and we had to have
standards even
when we were drawing by hand.
Really, it was almost more
important when we were drawing
by hand, because it was so
time-consuming and laborious
to make a drawing, that you
wanted to have certain drawings
that you could use
over and over.
It's just a little example
of what standardization does
to make things work
more efficiently.
We, as you all know, have an
issue in the federal government
where we were being
very duplicative.
We had different agencies
using different standards,
different platforms and
formats, and there was a lot
of taxpayer dollars going
to produce geospatial data
that wasn't being --
or wasn't in a way
that it could easily be
shared among agencies,
and I'm not sure the agencies
were even communicating to know,
you know, if one
agency had this data
that another agency
could possibly use.
So, that was the driver
behind doing this bill.
I was fortunate.
We got a very strong geospatial
data program in Arkansas.
the state director of
that, Shelby Johnson,
has been a longtime
friend of mine back
when I was just doing
engineering work,
before I ever got into politics.
I worked with Shelby at
the -- they called it CAST,
the Center for Advanced Spatial
Technologies at the University
of Arkansas, where my
undergraduate degree is from
and worked with Shelby there
and learned more and more
about geospatial data systems.
I went to forestry school
at Yale about the time
when foresters were
really starting
to use satellite imagery and
remote-sensing technologies,
and the amount of time that
you can save, and really,
the ceiling is still
way up there
on the advancements we can make
an understanding our natural
environment using
remote-sensing technologies.
But I got to kind of come in
in the early stages of that
and was able to use
that in my business
to make better decisions
and help the clients
that we were serving.
So, I've kind of got a
working knowledge of GIS
and the many ways that
it affects our lives,
much more than what was used
in my engineering business,
and I know that the way
technology is advancing
that remote-sensing and GIS
and spatial data is going
to be a more and more
important part of our lives.
I know that is an engineer, if I
went into an existing facility,
and we wanted to make
modernization to that facility,
we would spend days, if not
weeks, taking hand measurements,
making sketches, going back
and putting those sketches
into a drawing, so that we would
know what was there before we
got started.
I'm sure, and this is
what happens when you get
into Congress, you kind of get
out of touch with the details
that you used to like
to stay so close to,
but I know there were
sensing technologies
where you could go inside
an existing facility using
something like LIDAR and
measure everything in there
from different places and put
it all together in a 3D drawing,
and you can probably do that
very cost-effectively now,
and some of you may know
all about how to do that,
but there's just, like I
said, the sky's the limit
on where we can go with
geospatial data, and this bill,
I think, is a very good
start in getting standards
across the federal government,
which will probably affect
many things outside the
federal government.
I've got to say thank
you to Senator Hatch,
who was the Senate sponsor
on this bill and work so hard
to get it included
in the FAA bill.
When I'm on the Transportation
and Infrastructure Committee,
I'm on the Aviation
Subcommittee,
and had you asked me
this time last year
about getting the
geospatial data act as part
of the FAA bill, I would've
just given you a strange look,
but that's kind of the
way things happened here.
And I'm excited about where
the future will take us.
As you all know, what this bill
did was basically codified some
things in the -- that the
OMB had already put out,
codified the Federal
Geographic Data Committee
and also codified the National
Geospatial Advisory Committee.
It defined the geospatial
data infrastructure.
It talks about data
themes, and from there,
how to develop standards.
It talks about geoplatform,
and then,
it gets into the covered
agency responsibilities.
One of the hurdles we had
to get through and this was
with the Defense Department
and intelligence groups.
They didn't necessarily
want to share their data
across platforms, which
is understandable.
So, we carved out exemptions
for them, but the rest
of our agencies, hopefully,
as we move forward,
we'll see much easier, seamless
transition between sharing data
across agencies, and I'm
hoping that the oversight
that we established in this bill
will get more agencies talking
and sharing data and also making
that data more available
for the public.
So, we don't get to celebrate
that often Washington DC
about a big win like this,
but this really is a big win
that happened in
an unexpected way.
And again, I want to say
thank you for all the work
that you put into it, it is
just an honor for me to get
to be part of it, and you
know, this isn't going to be --
people actually not even heard
of the Geospatial Data Act.
They just know we passed
in FAA bill, and you know,
I go home to my constituents,
and they say,
"Well, what have you done?"
And I say, well, we got this
Geospatial Data Act passed,
and they look at me like,
that's what we elected
you to Congress to do?
I say, well, it actually
affects a lot of your life.
I said, if you use one of
those smartphones you got.
You pull up a map program.
I say, that's geospatial data.
I said, the weather that you
look at every day, I said,
there's just tons of ways
that geospatial data affects
your life, and we did something
to streamline that process and
make it more user friendly,
and hopefully, make life
better for more Americans.
It's not the sexiest thing in
the world, but I'm glad to be,
as a fellow nerd, I'm glad to
be part of the cause, and again,
appreciate your support.
Do we have time for
a few questions?
As long as they're
easy questions,
I'll take all of them.
[ Laughter ]
Well, those are really
easy questions.
Yes, ma'am.
>> Female: So, do you see,
when [speaking off
mic] are developed,
do you see this impacting
education at all?
>> Congressman Bruce
Westerman: I would hope so.
>> Female: How would
you foresee that?
>> Congressman Bruce Westerman:
So, I can give you a little bit
of a practical answer to that.
Back in my high-school days,
I had a friend who went
to West Point, and he was
just -- he just retired.
He'd gone back to West
Point as an instructor,
and he was teaching a
geospatial data class up there.
So, I went up to visit the
academy and visit his class,
and the students were very
interested in this bill,
in this legislation,
and I already know
that what we were talking about
in this bill was being carried
over into a class of future
geospatial data scientists.
And as the federal government
moves in a way to standardize,
I would think the natural
process would be for that
to move into the --
into higher education
and be implemented
in the classroom.
[ Female Speaking off Mic ]
Now maybe somebody might be
able to correct me on this
that knows more about the weeds
of the dealing with defense
and intelligence,
but my understanding
and my feedback was basically
that if we left the Defense
Department and NSA in the bill,
then it was going to
get a lot of pushback.
And so, we kind of
just left them alone
to do their own thing.
Now whether they eventually
will declassify information,
I think that will
be there decision
on whether they classify or what
of their data they make
available and what kind
of standards they use, but --
[ Female Speaking off Mic ]
You would think they
would want to do that,
but we pretty much left
them alone to enable
to get the bill enacted
as it is.
>> Male: Do you have any plans
for expanding [speaking
off mic]?
>> Congressman Bruce Westerman:
Whether I have plans or not,
I think, it's GIS is
going to be expanded.
I think it's definitely --
I don't think it's a
mature technology yet.
I know there's tremendous
amounts of use for GIS,
and we'll see more
and more than.
As much is it's -- you
know, for story was one
of the early adapters
of GIS technology,
and there's still a tremendous
amount of work that can be done
in forestry in an area that
have some expertise in,
and as you look at
all the other uses,
it's just, it's pretty amazing.
I had a fascinating conversation
with National Geographic,
probably it's been
within the last two years,
and they were talking about all
the mapping that they're doing,
the different kinds of mapping,
and it just makes your head spin
to think that there's
that much data out there
and all the analysis
we can do with it,
and I think it could
actually affect policy,
because you would hope
that lawmakers are looking
at the data that's available to
make the most informed decision,
and if you can get better data
in a more real-time situation,
then you can make
better decisions.
I was just looking at a map
on wildland urban
interfaces this morning,
which is all geospatial
data, with the wildfires
that are happening
out in California,
and we're seeing more and
more with warming temperatures
and drier conditions and more
people moving into the WUI,
as we call it, wildland-urban
interface.
I think we're going to have
to make some definite policy
changes and has some leadership
in the federal government
to address that government,
and GIS will be critical
in doing that.
So, it's everywhere.
It affects all the
parts of our lives.
People just -- I don't think the
general public realizes that,
how much they actually use it.
[ Female Speaking off Mic ]
Yeah, you would think so.
I served in my state
legislature, and I was there
in 2012, which after
the 2010 Census and part
of the state legislature's
duty was
to draw congressional districts.
I had was in the
minority, and I had no say
in how my congressional district
was actually drawn of the time,
but it was fascinating to me,
the tools that were available
in 2012, to take data by
precincts and start --
you could draw your own
maps and get real creative,
and I know that technology's
increased even more.
So yeah, it'll definitely
be used in census data.
>> Female: So, you mentioned
the disparity between standards
and what was being published in
the geospatial data environment.
You talked a little bit about
your background as an engineer
and also, the importance
in forestry,
but why was this bill
so important to you?
Why did you champion it?
>> Congressman Bruce
Westerman: Well,
I like to see things work
efficiently and effectively,
and I understand the
importance of standards
and common platforms, and I've
seen the success in Arkansas
with our GIS departments there
and the leadership, really,
that Shelby's been
able to bring to that,
and I just thought there was
a better way to do government
at the federal level, and
this is a good governance bill
that should save
taxpayers dollars
and provide a better service.
So, it was easy for me to
get on board to support it.
I wish we could find more pieces
of legislation like this.'
>> Male: So, [speaking
off mic] your final point.
I'm just curious if,
sort of looking ahead,
if there are more types of bills
or more types of initiatives
that you might need
jumping onto that,
that might relate
more efficiently
to geospatial education
or for promoting geospatial
technology development
in the government or beyond?
>> Congressman Bruce Westerman:
Yeah, and I think we need
to give this piece
of legislation time
to get implemented, and
there will always be tweaks
that need to be made.
I'm also a huge proponent
of STEM education,
which geospatial data
education would fall
in that stem category.
You know, I have four children,
one still in high school,
and they all got a little bit
of exposure to geospatial data
in a program called EAST, that
actually originated in Arkansas,
and I see programs like
than continuing to grow,
and it's amazing when the
interest it can create
in young people, who may have
never thought about a career
in STEM, when they
get to start playing
around with satellite
data and remote sensing
and building their own maps
and doing projects with that.
So, I think it will -- I think
the educational component will
come along to support the
science in the industry.
>> Female: What's
the timeline expected
for getting all the government
agencies on the same page,
as far as the standards go?
[speaking off mic]
>> Congressman Bruce
Westerman: I don't know
if an official timeline has been
established yet, but you know,
my response to the agencies
would be you're not done yet.
You know? And you all know
-- and this is a hard thing.
You know, we have huge
issues in the world today
with cybersecurity, which
GIS also can play a part
in cybersecurity, but one
problem with trying to legislate
and regulate anything that
has to do with technology,
and especially with
computer systems,
is that by the time government
gets the big massive slow
machinery moving and just
momentum, everything's changed.
So, it's got to be
something is responsive.
That's why hope that
these two committees
that have been codified
will work closely together
to monitor the situation and to
build something that can react
at the same speed that
technology changes today,
if that's at all possible
in the federal government.
I think that's a huge challenge,
and we all know how slow
the federal government moves
on things.
But this is one that
it really needs
to have a bigger
flame built under it,
I guess, to move faster.
And that's one thing that I will
keep pushing for, is following
up with, you know,
most of this is --
falls under the Department
of Interior.
So, we have a lot of
contacts over there
that we'll be following up with
to say where you at on this?
How can we help?
And, you know, what's your
timeline kind of thing?
But I think you all can
help with that, too.
Just because we've got a bill
signed into law doesn't mean
that anything's happened to it.
We've got to get
the code written
and get the agencies
to implement the law.
Well, again, thank
you for your time,
and I can't say enough
how humbled I am to get
to be the person that got to
carry this piece of legislation.
We'll make nerds proud
everywhere, and it's really,
really -- I can't express
enough how much your work
and efforts helped
to get this done.
Without your work and
efforts, we wouldn't get
to celebrate today
the fact that we got
to the geospatial data
act signed into law.
So again, thank you, and
if I can ever help you
with anything else, I'm
pretty easy to find.
God bless you all,
and have a good day.
[ Applause ]
>> Tim St. Onge: All
right, thank you again,
Congressman Westerman, for
that excellent keynote talk.
So, next up, I'd like to
introduce Candice Luebbering.
Candice is a senior research
geographer and director
of outreach and engagement
at the American Association
of Geographers.
She's the program coordinator
for the AAG-Esri GeoMentors
Program and assists
with a variety of AAG
programs and programs
that include research, outreach,
and membership engagement
activities.
She is a proudly self-labeled
map nerd, who loves promoting
and sharing geography and
GIS with all audiences.
She's also an avid tea drinker,
bike rider, and map hoarder,
owning more vintage atlases
than articles of clothing.
So, please welcome Candice.
[ Applause ]
>> Candice Luebbering:
Good morning.
>> Audience: Good morning.
>> Candice Luebbering: Thanks
so much for having me here.
Thank you to the Library of
Congress for putting this on,
to John Hessler, Tim, all of
your colleagues for having me.
First time following a
Congressman speaking.
That's a little nerve-racking.
I'm not going to lie.
But I'm really excited to
be here, in particular,
because the focus today is
on GIS in K-12 education,
and that's what our
GeoMentors Program is all about.
The GeoMentors Programs is a
nationwide network of volunteers
who are looking to do.
Find ways to insert GIS and
geography in spatial thinking,
any way we can, into
K-12 classrooms
and student groups
across the country.
So, that's what I'll
be talking about today.
So, the AAG is partnered
with Esri
for the GeoMentors Programs,
and this was borne out of,
starting in 2015, for
the GeoMentors Program,
Esri made a fantastic
donation saying, hey,
we've got this software
platform.
We will give it to any K-12
school the US that wants it
and wants to use it, which
is fantastic, and even now,
they've expanded that donation,
and Charlie, who'll speak
after me, will have a lot
more to say about this,
but now it's also available
to all K-12 schools
internationally, as well.
So, this is fantastic, right?
Students have the opportunity to
map with the same software that,
you know, industry
and government
and business were using around
the world, which is great.
But we can't always just, of
course, just take software
and drop it in the laps of K-12
schools, because they have tons
of time, right, to learn
new technology or find a way
to insert this in curriculum.
No, so, you know, as we had the
foresight of thinking, yeah,
this is a great gift, but
we know it's not going
to be the easiest
thing to implement.
So, with the free software
bundle, let's also bundle
in some free help,
and that's the idea
of having this GeoMentors
network.
Volunteers who will work with
a teacher, with the classroom,
with a school district, asking
them what they would like to do
with this technology,
kind of teaching them
about the technology,
and helping them implement
it in the classroom.
So, there's the best chance
for the software give
to actually get used.
Our current GeoMentors
network, as of yesterday,
was 1814 people who
have signed up.
So, every dot on this map is
someone who is, basically,
another Geo nerd,
who was like, yeah,
I want to help get kids mapping.
Who doesn't?
So, they're available.
This is an interactive map.
So, any teachers in the
room, you can go on here,
click on this, learn
about people,
find their contact information.
We also have a database.
So, you can search keywords.
You can have certain
topics you're teaching.
These are all people who
are interested, are ready,
and willing to work with a
teacher or with a youth group
or something like that.
So, teachers, again, see these
points as resources for you
and those of you
potential GeoMentors,
consider adding your
dot to the map.
So, this is a lot of volunteers,
which is great, but if you think
of how many schools and
classrooms there are to reach,
we could always use a few more
good people helping us out.
So, then your next
thought might be, well,
who can be a GeoMentor?
I run into so many people
thinking, can I be a GeoMentor?
If you're asking yourself,
if you're here on GIS Day,
if you know what GIS day is,
you're already super
qualified to be a GeoMentor.
And I'm not saying that
it's because, you know,
you don't have to
be an absolute whiz.
You're not going to
go into a classroom
and they expect you to, yeah,
I need you to Python
program to do this.
No, right?
So, I have a lot of people who
get intimidated and realize
and think I can't do it.
You have so much more
to offer than you think.
If you know what GIS is, if
you know the cool web map
and can lead a class
through asking questions
that can be answered spatially
by looking at imagery or,
you know, adding
different data layers.
That's being a great GeoMentor.
So, if you're here.
It's more the enthusiasm of
the passion that's a perquisite
than a certain type
or level of skills.
So, we're not just academics.
We're not just GISPs.
We're not just geographers.
So, it's anyone from undergrads.
They're some of our most
enthusiastic volunteers.
To retirees and everyone
in between,
from all different
disciplines, are our GeoMentors.
So, don't be intimidated
and think you don't know
enough to be a volunteer.
And you can really see the
diversity of our volunteers
by seeing just some of the
descriptions of who they are.
Again, not just geographers,
not just in academics
or something like that.
So, a biologist with the
National Park Service.
A teacher is also a GeoMentor.
So, we have teachers who are
using this in the classroom,
and then they're helping
other teachers to use it.
Undergrad students.
Really, they are fantastic
and enthusiastic and wonderful
as volunteers, because
they're not far removed
from the K-12 environment.
So, they have the connection
to get into the classrooms,
but they also remember
that experience
on how they want
to make it better.
A GIS tech at an
engineering firm.
So, urban planners.
A health educator who also
has a certification in GIS.
I like that, right?
Talk about diversifying on your
skill set in your portfolio.
So, what's good about this is
not just that it's interesting,
but we don't go into a school
and have a prescription
of what are you?
You're eighth grade.
All right, do this.
We know it would never work.
What our job really
is is to listen.
What would you like
to do with this?
What are you currently teaching,
and how can I help
you apply that?
And if you imagine all
the different, you know,
teachers in schools
across the country,
all have very different
interests
with what they're teaching,
with what's important
in their local area.
So, we need this broad spectrum
of volunteers to be able
to respond to this, to have
varying expertise and interests,
to have -- be able to respond
to their needs can cater to them
in what's going to be
important and useful for them
in using the technology.
All right, so who are they?
We covered that.
What exactly do you do?
All right, that was
the next thing.
All right, you're asking me
to sign up for something.
So, volunteers, what do you do?
Not the easiest answer, again,
because we don't have a playbook
that you take, all right?
So, really, the opportunities,
I often call this a choose
your own adventure volunteer
opportunity, because
it really is.
You're responding to
what a teacher or school,
or a student working
on project might have.
So, it's kind of as broad as
the applications of GIS itself.
So, a lot.
But the general areas of what
a lot of our volunteers do kind
of fall in four areas.
One, advocating for using GIS.
So, for most of us in
this room, check, right?
We are like, we know
GIS Is important.
That assumption actually does
not carry super far sometimes
outside of this room
for this building
or even agencies around here.
I think even hearing about the
Congressman making the case
that the Geospatial Data Act,
right, to his constituents.
Right? Unfortunately, people use
an interactive geospatial data
all the time, but they don't
necessarily make the connection
to the field of GIS
and all the work
that makes the magic
happen in their phone.
So, even just telling a
school about what this is,
that it's not just
something you can only use
that one grade level.
That it's not just something you
can only use with one subject.
That is something you can use
throughout the entire school.
That's a big feat.
That's something that
needs to be done.
So again, you don't
have to be a GIS was.
Can you talk about how it's cool
and how it could help
in the classroom?
Demonstrating existing
exercises to educators.
So, not having to
reinvent the wheel.
There are so many good resources
out there, lessons plans
and activities, and it's
a matter of, you know,
showing a teacher
that it's there
and walking them through it.
Helping them get
comfortable with leading it
in their own classroom.
So that they can carry out and
carry the torch themselves.
So, you don't always
have to completely come
up with all new things.
You're not building,
necessarily,
a whole semester's
worth of coursework
from them to implement.
Some people do.
Maybe they'll ask you to.
But often, it's just showing
them what's already available
and being that person
they can talk
to about it to implement it.
Sharing information about
careers in geography and GIS.
Again, and this room,
we're well aware
that this is a good
feel to be in.
There are a lot of
opportunities.
Even labor market
statistics say there's a lot
of growth opportunities,
but how many people heard
about be a geographer or be a
geoscientist in high school?
Yeah, exactly, right?
So, it's not one of those
typical career paths you hear
about at younger stages
and K-12, and yet,
it so the career
path that is open
to a world of opportunities.
You know, this type
of technology doesn't
really pigeonhole you
and to one discipline
at all, does it?
All right, so, if you're
a person that likes
to say undecided and do
all possible things, one,
you might end up
being a geographer.
That's what happened here.
But two, if you learn
this technology,
it doesn't put you
on a certain path.
There's so many different
ways they can apply it.
So, it's only going to be
more and more beneficial
to our discipline and to society
if we have students more aware
of these opportunities
at a younger age.
And then, finally, some
people do assist teachers
and group leaders with making
all new exercises with coming
up with survey one, two, three,
and running out in the field
and collecting data in a park
of things that are broken
and taking it to city council
and saying, "Hey, fix this."
That's happened.
That's been a group project.
You know, but finding new
data, collecting data,
building story maps,
new web apps.
So, some people do, from the
ground up, do entirely new,
customized things, again,
with a teacher or a classroom.
It all depends on what
they're looking for
and what you're interested in
and how much you can
help them with it.
So really, our GeoMentors
do a variety of things,
and you can work in person in
your local community schools,
but, I mean, this is
all about technology.
So, obviously, you can
work at a distance, right?
You can work with the teacher
across the country, you know,
and be their point of
contact to help them through,
answer questions, and
that kind of thing.
Great. That's what
they generally do,
but what did they actually do?
That's really going to drive
home what this program does,
what it can do, what you might
want to do if you're involved,
how you might want to work with
a GeoMentor if you're a teacher.
So, I'm just kind of
bringing up some quotes
and some little examples.
What I've learned from
running this program
with volunteers is they
are so excited sometimes
about doing this stuff, that
they don't tell me about it.
So, I actually have the
problem of people being more
into volunteering
than reporting.
Great problem to have, and
if you're only going to focus
on one thing, I want
you to do that.
So, I know there's so many
more stories out there
than even the ones that we have,
but I'll just highlight
a few today.
And these kind of show exactly
those kind of general categories
of what I said volunteers do.
So, meeting with juniors
and seniors at two
of our local high schools,
discussing with them what
a GIS career entails,
and the choices you
have with a GIS career.
So, just actually
going somewhere
and telling people what you
do every day, maybe to you,
you're already like, I
know I do that every day.
But to them, it's completely
something new they've never
heard of them thought, I did
not know that was a job, right?
Anytime a student kind of
hear something like that,
you've just opened up a whole
kind of opportunity and,
you know, who thought I didn't
know that's something you
could do.
Whether or not it's something
they're interested in,
but even making them aware
of these possibilities.
So, one, you are an expert
what you do every day.
So again, if you think you can't
be a GeoMentor, you know to do?
Yes, okay, can you
talk about it?
Probably, hopefully, right?
And so, that's already
being a great GeoMentor.
I visited a middle school
in Riverside, California.
They're learning about
earthquakes and architecture.
So, I'll demonstrate how 3D GIS
and ArcGIS online can be
used to model such events.
So, this is a lot
of what it's about.
What are you guys already
teaching and learning?
Okay, hey, so we could visualize
this in a different way.
Let's just check it out.
What do you think?
All right, so we're not
supplanting curriculum.
We're finding out
ways to say, hey,
would you like to
see this differently?
Would you like to look
at this spatially?
Would this be a something
of interest to your students
to learn this topic
in a different way?
And it's stuff, you know,
not just connecting them
to what they're learning,
but especially
if they're learning something
applicable to their environment.
They're in California.
Earthquakes and architecture.
This is not a foreign
thing, far, far away.
Again, this is something
they can connect with
and imagine how much more
this topic might drive home
if they see it visualized
spatially in this way.
My son's school just
registered for their account.
Principal and IT
specialist are both excited,
as is his kindergarten teacher.
Kindergarten.
That's awesome.
So, this is another big task
is just getting them aware
of what it is and, yeah,
getting them excited about it,
even just a little bit
excited, compared to the level
that we are or I am about it.
It's a really big, important
step is getting them aware
of this, excited, and
getting them on board.
So, that's something that a lot
of our GeoMentors do, as well.
I'm just going to keep showing
this stuff, because I love it.
So, I always share this one.
Charlie's probably seen me
talk about this so many times.
"I reached out to my daughter's
fourth grade Challenge Program.
I shared a bunch of
resources with her
and inadvertently caused her to
change her entire lesson plan
to incorporate GIS (oops)."
We don't often want oops
moments, right, in our lives,
but we want these oops
moments, where the teacher now,
and I think that's part
of the program, too,
is it's not just how the
students can get more excited
but the teachers
can get more excited
about what they're
already doing, all right?
Maybe something they taught
every year, year in, year out,
and you know, they're
passionate about it, but oh,
a new way of teaching it
is invigorating for them,
as much as it is
for the students.
So, and we didn't force her
to change her lesson plan.
They were excited to.
So, that's another
important part, too.
But we want more oops moments,
more excitement moments.
And this next one is just
something about volunteering.
I think that was -- kind of
came through in this quote.
"I'm about to reach out to my
daughter's sixth grade social
studies teacher.
He's expecting my email.
This will be the first time
doing anything like this.
Pretty scary for me, but
I have to get over it."
Just like I have to get
over public speaking, right?
So, a big part of this,
again, do I know enough
to be a GeoMentor and, oh, I
have to put myself out there.
And you do, and it is
scary, but I encourage you
in the most positive way
possible what I say this,
get over it.
I encourage you to put
yourself out there, and again,
you'll get so much
validation out of this
in realizing how much
you have to offer,
how much the technology
knowledge you have can go beyond
your daily frame of
reference of what you work in
and help students
get excited about it.
So, yes, I probably should not
tell a crowd of people to get
over it, but I just did.
So, that happened.
And then, we just get to
see the stories come in,
and it's super exciting.
Top left there, not
everyone uses GIS
when they do GeoMentoring.
That's fine.
Wall maps or even just talking
about spatial thinking,
all right?
It doesn't have to be GIS.
So, with younger kids, we do
have GeoMentors who will just go
in sometimes with
a giant wall map.
National Geographic has
those huge floor maps
of the states that
are fantastic.
So, kids will run around in
socks, hopping around on,
you know, cities
and mountain ranges.
Bottom left, actually, it's an
undergraduate geography society
at a university partners with
a local high school and takes
over the classroom
for a couple days
to teach high schoolers
with ArcGIS online.
In the center there, working
with the AP GIS class,
making custom web maps.
Can you imagine getting to do
that at the high school level?
I started learning
GIS when I was 24,
and I felt young starting at 24.
But when I think of just a
different way of thinking
and the future of the field
and innovation that will come
from students intuitively
knowing how to work
with this stuff at a younger
and younger age, it's exciting.
Top right, working with a
Girls Innovation Academy.
Again, that sounds supercool.
I want to go back in time
and be in these things,
but teaching geo referencing
and wetlands mapping.
And the bottom one, an example,
again, of working at a distance.
So, Rob Spacecraft, he actually
puts that on his name badges
at conferences, Spacecraft
as to go by.
Fun with names.
Puns with names.
But he virtually mentored
students in California,
who were working on story map
submissions for a contest.
So, wasn't even in the same
place, but could go back
and forth and advise
them, help them find data,
and that sort of thing.
And I'll just keep sharing more.
So, this picture,
top left to Justin.
He's the one who had a paper
map with the younger kids,
but now you see him
teaching, you know,
digital mapping with
an older crowd.
So, adapting with the students
or with what's available
in the classroom, right?
You just have to adapt.
So, this is a very good
exercise in adapting.
Top right, Annette
in Pennsylvania does
amazing jobs working
with all these different schools
and getting just the
most adorable, you know,
activities of kids going
out and doing surveying
and collecting data in
the field, and of course,
can you spot the
geospatial professional
in a sea of fourth-graders?
I'll give you a moment.
And maybe it's because he or
she, you know, is really blended
in there, or maybe it's because
the fourth-graders are looking
more and more like
geospatial professionals.
I don't know.
I'll leave that is
food for thought.
And really, the other
thing is, this also,
it's not just one directional
of GeoMentors are out going
and doing a thing and just
students are benefiting.
I really found that
everyone kind of benefits,
and you don't necessarily
predict
which way the geomentoring
really is going to happen.
So, I don't know if you see
our tiny man-big vest here
in the front left, right?
That's Oliver, and Oliver is the
son of his geomentor dad next
to him, and when his geomentor
dad goes and does drone exhibits
and kind of demonstrations for
classrooms, Oliver goes with him
and is super jazzed about it.
He likes to help.
He likes to be the helper.
So, while I know
there's a classroom
of students here learning about
drones, I think there's a lot
of geomentoring here
between Oliver and his dad,
and we've got a geomentor
in training here.
And he's learning about what his
dad does and what's interesting
about this, and he's learning
about teaching other
students, as well.
So, there's a lot of
positive, multidirectional kind
of benefits out of these
geomentoring opportunities.
So, maybe I have some of
you hooked thinking, I mean,
maybe I could do that possibly.
So, how do you get involved?
It's painless.
I promise.
You just sign up online,
and you're not obligated
to anything, assigned
anything, required anything.
You just get in our
communication loop.
So, you'll get emails.
He'll get newsletters, and
you'll be a dot on the map.
So, educators and schools can
find you and reach out to you.
If there are educators in
the room, and you would
like to also put
your name out there
and saying, hey, I want help.
We have a sign up for
educators, as well.
So, if you sign up, then
GeoMentors will be notified,
and they can contact you, and
you can say what you're looking
for and what kind
of help you want.
And once you've signed up, and
if you're ready at some point,
and I will say, we ask
GeoMentors to get involved
when they can to the
extent that they can.
Maybe it's a one-time thing.
Maybe it's an ongoing
collaboration for a semester,
or a year, or beyond, but
every little bit helps.
So, I don't think I only
have this much time.
So, I can't do it, or
that kind of thing.
We don't have any limitations
or anything like that.
Again, every little bit helps to
be the spark for the educator,
the spark for the
student, a spark for you.
So, connecting with
a collaborator,
I will be straightforward,
it's not always the easiest
to make roads into
the K-12 communities.
Charlie knows a lot
more about that.
So, sometimes this can be
the most challenging thing.
As a GeoMentor, you can, first
of all, see what educators are
out there requesting help.
We do tend to have more
volunteers putting their name
on the map then educators.
Contact local schools
in your area.
You can see which schools have
signed up for the software
and which ones haven't.
So, that's a strategy of
go to schools that have
or approach schools that
haven't and tell them about it,
if you want to do that
kind of advocacy angle.
You can also work
with youth groups,
because they're also
eligible to get free software.
So, maybe you've volunteered
with Boy Scouts or Girl Scouts
or 4-H or Boys and
Girls Clubs of America.
Those are options too, or
afterschool clubs affiliated
with schools, as well.
So, think outside the box.
What are environments
that students are
in that I could work with?
But we really encourage
people to work
through your social network.
Most people have a connection
to K-12 in their life, right?
So, it's their kids' school.
Their friend is a teacher.
Their alma mater, right?
So, think of it that way.
One, it makes little bit easier.
People know who you are
and why you want to help,
because you're just
invested, and you're kind
of more invested,
too, because you know
who you're helping already.
But you could be the
person that brings GIS
to your elementary
school, right?
So, your middle school
to your high school.
Again, a lot of parents
who are working
with their own kids' teachers.
Some of them follow
them through the grades.
So, they'll work with the grade
level that their child is at,
and they're going and adapting.
And so, they're starting
with elementary.
Now they're in middle and
adapting their skills,
as well, with doing that.
And again, for those who
are seeking a GeoMentor,
the online map is there,
but there's also a
database, as well.
So, you can connect and
find people that way.
And we don't just say, woo-hoo!
Sign up! We try and put as much
resources as we can in one spot
to have more than enough
to get you started.
So, if you go to our website,
you know, we have information
on how to find people.
How to talk to them.
Also, how to connect
with each other.
We do want this to
be a community.
So, we have online communities.
We have social media.
How you can share
your story, and also,
a review other people's
stories, as well.
And you can gain service and
outreach experience, which,
in and of itself, is
fulfilling, but some people,
particularly undergrads who are
looking to have more experience,
if you tell us about your story,
which we really want you to do,
we'll document it and
give you a certificate,
and anyone who is an
aspiring GISP, right,
this can work towards your
accreditation or your renewal.
And I mentioned the
case studies.
This is how you can
really find out more
about these variety
of experiences.
We have over 40 case studies
from 27 different states,
and these are people who
took the time to write a lot
about their experience.
How did they find someone?
You know, how much
time did it take?
That's something
we want to know.
What did they teach?
What worked well?
What didn't work well?
And what did they
learn from experience?
How was it for them?
So, I encourage you to go
online and check those out,
and what we really
hear is, again,
how much our volunteers
get out of it.
All right?
So, it's invigorating to
have students show enthusiasm
in what each of us have
chosen as a career.
Or as Diana said, "It encouraged
me in my day-to-day work.
It reminded me of how fun GIS
can be and how it can be applied
to almost everything
you do daily."
I think sometimes we forget
that, oh, yeah, this is fun.
Right? Oh, yeah, you can
use this for a lot more
than just what I do
in my discipline here.
So, I think this can actually
be really reinvigorating
for our volunteers, as well.
So, I encourage you, if
you're not signed up,
if you'd like to sign up or
at least check us out online,
reach out to us on Twitter,
email, and all that,
and I want to thank you again
for having me here
today and happy GIS Day.
[ Applause ]
>> Tim St. Onge: All right,
thank you very much, Candice.
So, I will remind everyone
again that at the end
of all these talks, we will have
all the presenters up again,
so you can ask questions,
so we can have more
of a full-range discussion
with everybody.
So, if you have any
questions, don't worry.
Candice is sticking around
for a while and will be able
to answer questions and will
be able to have that discussion
at this point at maybe about
11:30ish, but for right now,
I'd like to introduce our next
speaker, Charlie Fitzpatrick.
Charlie has been Esri's schools
program manager since 1992,
focused on K-12 classroom
use in the US.
He taught social studies
in grades seven through 12,
mostly eighth-grade geography
in St. Paul, Minnesota.
So, please welcome
Charlie Fitzpatrick.
[ Applause ]
>> Charlie Fitzpatrick:
Nobody's asked for this so far.
So, are there any
teachers out there?
We've got a handful.
Yay! And some of who have
been who will say, oh,
that's one of the best
times of our lives.
Well, so, I get to -- I have
one of the three or four jobs
that Jack Dangerman, the head
of Esri, would like to have.
And so, this is always a big
responsibility for me to come in
and talk with people
about what's available?
What's possible?
Because there's so many
things that people are doing,
and you look at these
pictures and think, wow,
everybody's doing stuff.
And well, yes and no.
And it's important to
understand a little bit
about why this came to be.
So, I got to start in the
old days, back in 1992,
with the dawn of ArcView 1.0,
and it was on Windows 3.1,
and very few people, very few
teachers, had access to machines
and were comfortable with
them and had time to mess
around with them, and
there was no curriculum.
And so, ArcView 1 was out.
And then ArcView 2, and by the
time that ArcView 3 was around,
there were things
that people could do.
There were some activities.
There were some projects,
and really, it was projects
that made it happen for people.
Getting people to say,
hey, there's a thing
that I really want to explore,
and that's been the
watchword all the way through,
whether it's I want to take
a look at the watershed
in my community, or I
want to see the world
in several different
projections,
or I have this battle that I
really like to think about.
There's something that people
want to do in their class
and have the time and
have the passion to do,
but it was really the
oddball way back then.
Then about 2000, things
started to roll fast.
We came out with this GIS
in schools, but with a set
of case studies of
what people are doing
and some best practices.
And 2002 was a real
watershed, because we came
out with this big green
book, Mapping our World.
And that was a curriculum where
there was the software in place,
and there were activities
for world geography
that people could go through,
and they were doing it
from third and fourth
grade on up
into grad school using
that one resource.
And they been doing that
over the years with ArcView 3
and then ArcView 9
and then ArcView 10
and then ArcGIS online.
That resource has
been fairly timeless,
but what also happened
back in 2000 was
that kids started appearing
up on the Esri user
conference stage,
and you can see in the top left.
There's a group that
is sitting on top
of this thing called
the geography network,
which was starting to get
to be online capacity,
and they were actually
some of the first users
of the geography network.
They were working with
some data from online.
So, this was something
that was, you know,
presaging the big
change that was coming.
The group in the top right,
they look like little munchkins.
They were fourth-graders who
came up on stage and were able
to prove to people what
it is that kids can do,
because these guys said, hey,
Department of Natural Resources,
your model about what these
toads, with these tiny,
little horny toads in
central Washington,
that they only travel of
thousand feet in their life,
but the ones that
we're tracking,
they've traveled three,
four times that much.
So, your models are wrong.
So, go fix them.
And so, that was really
important for people to get
to see that students
can do a lot.
So then came these,
you know, that whole --
this world that you
see in the center came
out with the mapping
our world book,
and it was a powerful
thing for people to see.
That this is what GIS people do.
This is this geographic inquiry
process that they go through,
and a lot of people who were
science teachers will look
at this and say,
well, of course.
Everybody's doing this.
No, not everybody was doing
this, and certainly not
so much social studies teachers.
I was a social studies teacher,
but I grew up as a biologist,
and so it's that science thing
that helps people see I need
to be approaching these
things scientifically.
I always wanted my kids to be
exploring and messing with data,
and that's what you got
to do with these tools.
Well, and that's what happened
with some of the materials,
the software, but started coming
out for integrating both
desktop data and online data.
So, you can see in the far
right, Arc Explore Java Edition
for Education that
came out in 2007,
and then ArcGIS Explorer,
and then, okay.
Come on, you can
scroll down here.
Let's see.
Let me smallerize this
one more a notch here.
All right, then we can get to --
how about if I move
the mouse over here?
All right, well, we'll
just deal with that.
ArcGIS Explorer, and then,
the ArcGIS online came out.
And then, some apps
working with ArcGIS online.
So, things were really
starting to happen at the end
of these 2010-2011 year,
and in 2012, my God,
the world just went -- exploded.
ArcGIS Online organizations
came out, and people finally,
in schools, had a way to have
students be able to safely
and securely be able to share
and collaborate and work
across activities, across
classrooms with each other.
There were all kinds of ways
that they could do this,
and Jack ran into
[inaudible], who introduced him
to this school, and he
said, "I think we want
to work with the school."
And what they were able to do,
they had two fabulous teachers
who were at this
math-science-technology
magnet academy.
It was the social studies
teacher and the English teacher
who took GIS and ran with it,
because they converted what
was already a great project,
a research project, and to
a really powerful thing,
and in three months,
they went from, okay,
we now have computers we
can turn on two, Jack,
this is the group that
needs to be up on stage.
When you have teachers that
are really good teachers,
and you expose them to GIS,
powerful things happen.
And so, they came
onto the stage.
They show people what was
possible, and that was
about the time when President
Obama was saying, hey,
we want private industry
to help education.
Jack heard that said, okay.
We're going to do that, and
as Candice was talking about,
we're going to do that.
We're going to provide software
to any school that wants it.
We're going to provide mentors.
We're going to provide
instructional materials,
and we're going to provide
some teacher support.
So, we're going to
make that stuff happen,
and that was this Connect
Ed program that started out,
and as we jumped in in 2014, and
the biggest thing that we jumped
into was working
with geo inquiries.
One of my colleagues, Tom Baker,
said, okay, we've got to come
up with materials that
Joe Teacher, Jane Teacher,
without GIS background, can
incorporate into their class,
into work that they're
already doing.
So, he has, over the
last couple years,
built with teachers helping him
out, built in these nine sets
of 15 to 20 lessons for anybody
to use with no GIS background.
So, how do they work?
Well, what happens is
there is a two-page,
back and front PDF
for every lesson.
That two-page PDF includes a
color bar on the first page
where it's got a URL to its
own unique preconstructed map.
So, all of these lessons, 150
lessons, that lead to content
that is the stuff that teachers
are doing in their standard,
regular classroom activities.
They're working on
standard content.
So, it's Edgar Allan Poe.
It's the Civil War, or it's
earthquakes and plate tectonics
and watersheds and linear
rates of development
and whatever happens to be.
Oh, and there's elementary
that is an integrated
set of content, as well.
Teachers can do this with
very little background,
and it'll work even in just
one computer in a classroom
with a projector, but
if you have students
that have devices,
all the better.
And so, this has been
extremely powerful,
because no login is required.
They can do this in 15 minutes,
or if they decide, oh, hey,
we want to mess around
with the software,
it may take a little bit longer.
But it's all good.
Now what has come of that?
You introduce people to
some of these geo inquiries
where they get to do these
activities, and they say, great.
I want more.
Where's more?
Well, a level two.
So, we've been creating
these level-two geo inquiries
that say now we want you to
get into doing some analysis.
To do that, you actually
have to log
in with an organization
account and be able
to have publishing capacity,
but when you can do that,
you can do geographic analysis.
So, this particular lesson,
this dustbowl, is looking at --
it's a summarize within
activity, where you're going in
and taking a look at how
many are within this zone.
And so, there are all kinds
of analytical capacities
that are built into ArcGIS
online, and what's happening is
that teachers are starting
to get exposed to this
and discovering, while.
This is pretty powerful.
This is pretty cool, and those
organizations are available
at no cost to any
school in the country,
and that's what a lot
of schools are doing.
So then, what you
see is a couple
of different examples here.
So, in the bottom right,
let's start with that one.
Here you see an AP
human geography class
that is happening in two
schools at once with one teacher
that is a virtual situation
in the other school.
So, you can see the other
school in the left-hand monitor,
and you can see the presentation
that he's walking his students
through in two schools at
once, just with a big monitor.
That's very doable, even
if you don't have a really
big monitor like that.
This was a very cool classroom.
I love this.
And you can see, actually,
if you get in and take a look
at it, the students all have
devices on their machines.
So, he's walked them
through some things,
and now he's saying, okay,
here's what I want
you to explore.
So, now in three
different classrooms
in these other pictures,
you're seeing students,
and they're all working
on iPads here.
The fellow with the broken
arm in the top-left corner,
he's actually got
the teacher material
that he's been working with.
And this teacher said,
hey, I like my science kids
to be working with the actual
content that I get to see.
I want them to go
through the exact steps,
and we interrupt them
every now and then.
And so, he was very good,
skilled at doing that.
The student below in the
lower left, he's working
on a social studies one,
looking at the Middle East,
with a worksheet
from the teacher
that the teacher has specially
created and said, you know,
go through these activities
and work your way through it.
And the student on the top
right has no worksheet at all.
That student and that
class, they're going through
and saying, hey, this is
what we want you to explore.
You've got 10 minutes
to get in and explore
and tell me what you
found afterwards.
And so, there are a lot of
different ways of working
with these things,
teaching standard content.
So that's been very helpful,
and people get to the end
of that and they say, great.
I want more.
Where do I go?
So, people inside Esri
and beyond have been
building these materials.
There's a book that came
out, the ArcGIS book,
and what that says is it
provides people a number
of activities that
they can go through.
Well, they've added to that some
lessons that they also said,
hey, let's open it up
and bring some lessons
that are just designed
for teachers.
And so, there are three
different types of lessons,
and one of the mentors
said, "My God,
the kids are just downloading
the book or the lesson
on to their phone,
and they're doing it
on the computers,
and they love it.
They're focused.
They're so into it,"
which is great.
That's what we want
people to do.
And one of the best examples of
that is happening in Virginia,
where the Virginia Geospatial
Semester, which is a program
that is coordinated by
James Madison University,
is running through and they've
got about 500 students this year
that are going through that.
Mostly 12th graders.
There are a few 11th
graders going through it.
Science, social studies,
and some CTE teachers.
But that's not the
only way to do that.
There are also people,
as Congressman was talking
about, the East Initiative.
So, these folks are working
through, in Arkansas,
there are 250 schools
in Arkansas
that are participating
in this program.
It is a project-based,
high-tech,
individualized service
learning project.
And so, people are going
through and learning GIS.
High schools, most high
schools in Arkansas,
many middle schools, and a few,
even elementary schools,
kids are doing GIS.
And so, you can see some
map-based activities
in the example on the website,
but a lot of students are going
through and just exploring it.
The two kids that are over here
on the left, munchkins again.
Fourth-graders who were up on
stage in 2014 doing something,
and they showed it, and
those kids saying, hey,
we took our balloon data,
and let's display it in 3D,
and let's make a movie of it.
And people came up
to me afterwards
and said the students are
doing things that we don't do.
So once again, yep,
you can do it,
if you just get the
chance to do it.
And in Michigan, the Grace
Program was a very powerful
thing that said we want to
start with the teachers learning
about this through
geo inquiries.
Mentor them to go beyond that.
Maybe inspire the teachers
to get the students
to do some additional training,
and then the savvy kids can
qualify for internships.
And they had about 150 or
200 kids over the last couple
of years get summer internships,
paid summer internships
with what they're doing.
And there's a little town in
Michigan where there is a kid
who is working through his 12th
grade year, and he will graduate
with three years in the
county GIS shop at the time
that the only GIS user in
the county is retiring.
He may not have to
go to college,
but as Candice mentioned,
clubs are available, too.
They're doing all
kinds of cool things.
Here we've got the 4-H
group that is showing some
of their health programs
in the background,
and over on the left-hand
side, in 2017, 4-H(ers) were
up on stage looking at, because
they had an interstate health
program that they
were looking at,
four states that they
were collaborating
on this research project
and putting it together.
This was a fabulous
presentation, getting people
to see what's possible
with that work.
So, we've taken that and said,
okay, what we want to do is --
let me smallerize this
just a little bit,
see if we can wrap that -- ooo.
There, you get to see, actually,
the winners from this past year,
the middle school and
high-school winners.
There's a competition that says
put together, in a team of one
or two, a research project
and put together a story map.
So, you can go -- let me
just hit that one again,
so that you can see -- then
I'll give you the address,
if you like.
And the big national prize
across the country is you get
to come to the user conference,
which is always great
for students who haven't
ever been on a plane.
But you get to see
all of their maps.
Now it's not just for students.
We've also got an
opportunity for people
to see what other
teachers are doing.
So, we've created a
little challenge program
for the teachers.
Put together a one-minute video.
Take a look at it.
We're going to look across
the country at the ones
that we really want to
highlight and say, here.
These are the ones that
people should take a look at.
And so, you're seeing
science teachers,
social studies teachers,
CTE teachers
at all different grade levels
and the things that
they're doing.
It's a very powerful way to
explore this, and there are some
of the teachers that are putting
out independent materials
on their own for
people to work with.
So, there are lots of
opportunities for people
to think about where do
we fit this stuff in?
And what you're seeing
now is that map that shows
that there are thousands of
schools across the country
that are already doing
this and thousands more
who haven't gotten
into doing this,
because they've only been
exploring the geo inquiries.
And so, you can go
in and explore this.
Esri.com/schools will take
you to all the information
that you can shake a stick at,
all the information
that you really need.
You can get software for the
schools in your neighborhood,
and there are things that your
kids can do just starting in.
All grades.
Well, Candice and I could
probably talk all the rest
of the day, but you've got
more people to present.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Tim St. Onge: Thank
you very much, Charlie.
All right, moving along,
our next speaker is
Kathleen McGuigan.
She is an education resource
specialist here at the Library
of Congress, with over 25 years'
experience working on behalf
of K-12 education
for national groups.
In her current role,
she is responsible
for building online teacher
programs here at the library.
So, please welcome
Kathleen McGuigan.
[ Applause ]
>> Kathleen McGuigan:
Good morning.
My name's Kathy McGuigan,
and I work in the learning
and innovation team, and we're
part of the new center here
at the library, which is
called the Center for Learning,
Literacy, and Engagement,
and I do have the pleasure
of building teacher
programs and products
for educators using
libraries' collections,
that's what I'm going to talk
about a little bit today,
a project that we started last
summer looking at literary maps.
Excuse me.
So, what we're looking at are
some of the foundational steps
that we're taking to visualize
the library's catalog for,
and we're really focusing
on American literature,
and I'll go into a little
bit more of the specifics.
But I was very excited to hear
from our past two speakers
about the mentoring aspect
to this and the access
that schools will have,
because really, what I'm talking
to the -- the audience I'm
talking to you today, really,
are the educators in
the crowd and talking
about how I'm approaching
this project
from the educator perspective.
So, what is a literary map?
A literary map is a
map, or it's a picture,
that acknowledges the
contributions of authors
to a specific area or region.
It can also be a map, or
a picture, of locations
of works within fiction.
So, I want to show you
a couple of examples
of some literary maps that we
have here in the collection
at the Library of Congress in
our Geography and Maps Division.
So, this map is the
pictorial chart
of American Literature
from 1932.
And this is a Book Lovers map
of the United States from 1949.
Next up is the Iowa
literary map from 1934
from the Davenport Library.
And here we have the Texas
literary map of 1955,
and this comes from the
Dallas Public Library.
And lastly, in terms
of our examples,
this is the Maine Writers
map, and this comes
from the Maine Council
of Teachers of English,
and this is from 1981.
So, in approaching this
project, there was, in 1993,
there was an exhibition
here at the Library
of Congress called
Language of the Land,
Journey into Literary America,
where these literary maps
that the library houses
were put onto display,
and this exhibition went on the
road and traveled to 16 states
and 20 different sites, and
as part of their programming,
state centers for the
book, and I'll get
into what a State
Center for the Book is.
They started producing
literary maps.
And then, those maps, as well as
other maps from the collections,
are in this particular book,
which is called the same
as the exhibition
Language of the Land,
Journeys into Literary America.
This was published in 1999.
And so, when I learned
about the literary maps here
at the Library of Congress, it's
something that has really stuck
in my head since I've been here.
I've been here for 11
years, and a long time ago,
I was an English teacher, right?
And so, I was thinking about
how you could use these
instructionally with your
students, but beyond that,
in looking at some of the maps,
right, figuring out the folks
who selected the authors
that are displayed
on this map may look very
different to your students,
in terms of building
their own literary map
and celebrating different facets
of their literary history.
So, last year, I had
the pleasure of working
for the Center for the Book,
which is also in the Center
for Learning Literacy
and Engagement,
and as part of that work,
the state centers --
we have a state center for
the book in all 50 states,
and they are about reading
promotion, literacy promotion,
and celebrating poetry.
So, taking some pieces
of the programming
that the library does on behalf
of constituents and rolls them
out through the state.
And so, several states had
mentioned that they were looking
at using GIS to do
their literary maps.
And so, what we decided to do
was to form a committee, right?
That's what you do.
So, we formed a committee
with several of the states
who were already in this
field looking at this project
and how you take your literary
map from a paper product
and map that out using GIS.
So, we're working with the
state of Illinois, Mississippi,
Pennsylvania, Washington,
Minnesota, and Montana.
And so, I just want to
show you a quick example.
This is a project from Montana
and the Montana Authors Project.
And really, what they did
is just mapped out the books
that they selected from
their physical literary map
and mapped it out using GIS.
This is another project.
This is the Washington
State Center for the Book,
and this is called Finding
Books in Washington.
And so, they were looking at it
from an end-user's perspective.
How do they serve
their constituents
in getting access to books?
So, they've mapped out
the public, academic,
and tribal libraries, as well
as independent bookstores
throughout the state.
And then, the last
example I want
to show here is the
Illinois Center for the Book.
They have a very robust
database that they maintain,
which is called the
Illinois Writers Project.
And not only does the state
center nominate writers to be
in the Illinois Writers Project,
but writers themselves
can self-selected nominate
themselves for the
Writers Project.
So, you can see, this
is a very dense project.
So, one of the things
that we did in meeting
with the groups is to really
map out one of the paper maps
and map it out on
the Esri platform.
And so, here you can see
a side-by-side comparison.
I'm not sure how big this
is actually showing up,
but this is the Arizona Literary
map, and it is then laid
out for looking at
the catalogue records
that we have here
at the library.
And it was just the start
what I'm going to be talking
about in mapping this out.
I know you all know this,
but I just want to talk
about the benefits of doing
something like this is
that we can talk about
exact geographic location.
And this becomes more
accessible to a larger audience.
Again, if you take one of those
physical maps, a literary map,
students might not recognize
themselves within those writers,
within that particular area,
and if you put it into the hands
of the students to determine
what facets they would use
to lay out their own map, you
know in using the Esri platform
and GIS in particular,
it's a matter
of easily editing
the information,
and most importantly, you
can incorporate large amounts
of data.
So, and I'll get into
a little bit more
of what we're looking at here.
And it serves as an
intuitive educational tool,
as our last two speakers
have talked to you about.
So, looking at the
library's records.
In 2017, the library
released 25 million records
of their catalog, and
as part of that release,
what they did was they
also sponsored a hackathon,
where they invited groups
in and at their sites
to start taking a
look at the data.
And so, there was a lot of
great work that was done,
in terms of being able
to look at what is needed
to extract the data
within those sets.
And we know within
the MARC records.
So, what is a MARC record, for
those who are not familiar?
It's a machine-readable
cataloging record.
So, it's the basis of the
collections here at the library.
And within the fields,
and I'm not a librarian.
So, for the librarians
in the crowd,
I just want to put
that out there.
So, but there is a field within
the MARC records, which is 651,
and that is a field that locates
where the work takes place.
So, if we were to look at all
of the geographical information
within a MARC record,
you would have the place
where books are published.
That is actually
in the MARC record,
but you would see
a great influx,
if you were taking a look at
American fictional records
with that in New York.
So, what we're really
trying to take a look at is
where does the work
of fiction take place?
And that happens
within these MARC tags,
and in particular, in field 651.
So, this is the MARC
record for one
of the most popular novels
that's taught in schools,
which is The Great
Gatsby, right?
And so, taking a look
at the MARC record
for The Great Gatsby,
we get to field 651,
and as you would expect, it
says Long Island, New York.
So, taking that one step
further, mapping it out,
this is transcribing the
MARC record and putting it
on to -- into the map.
So, in talking about how do we
move forward with this project?
And again, when you start
looking at the amount of data
that is out there with
the 25 million records,
how do you start
making sense of this?
And so, there are so many smart
people here at the library,
and several of them
are in the room,
and I want to thank you all for
helping me with this project.
So, I sat down and talked
with a number of experts
within the library, and
someone made the suggestion,
you should get a junior fellow.
This is an intern that comes
and spends six or seven weeks
with us here at the library,
and just invite this person
in to start taking
a look at the --
at what they did in
the hackathon and look
at what your committee is trying
to -- what their goals are,
and let's play around
a little bit.
So, we put the call out,
and thankfully, we got --
he's now a senior at the
University of Georgia majoring
in GIS and comparative
literature,
and his name is Josh Clifford.
And you will hear from him
in the future, I'm sure,
but he couldn't be here today.
So, he came on board,
and we, essentially,
gave him the project
and said, good luck.
And so, one of the first things
that he did was to take a look
at all of the data sets and
focus in on one of the parts.
So, those 25 million records
are in 41 different parts.
And so, we narrowed that 41
parts down to part 41, and so,
what he did is started
editing the data
within that using a
tool called MARCEdit,
and then he refined this.
For those GIS professionals in
the room, you know far better
than I do how much time it takes
to really get into the data sets
and make sure that
they are consistent,
and then translated them
and cleaned up the records,
and then, finally,
mapped them out.
So, we did not get
anywhere near mapping
out the American fictional
records, but I will share
with you what we
were able to do.
So, the part 41 that
he was taking a look
at had 250,000 records.
And so, the processing
power that you need
to even start refining the
data in this is pretty intense.
And as I mentioned before, he
used MARCEdit to look at that.
And then, he moved that from
MARCEdit into Open Refine.
And doing these steps was just
to assess how many records
had data in field 651,
because it is not complete
at all, whatsoever.
And more recent records may
have that data the way we want
to ingest it, but older records,
in some cases, will
not have that.
So, then he brought it
into Excel, and we started
to focus on Washington State.
It was a manageable piece of
information that we could do
in the six to seven weeks that
he was here in Washington.
And so, we focused on the State
of Washington and identified
where we could find information.
In a lot of cases, you'll
see just Washington labeled
and not a specific
area within Washington.
So, what he did is then he
took the data and related out,
and where we had
Washington identified,
and his key here is
this particular area.
This has 192 records,
because this just Washington.
And then, the other
areas around the state
where the actual
city is listed out.
So, this is the translation,
and looking at the title,
the author, the year published,
the geographic ID, and then,
he went into another platform
and extracted the book cover,
so that it can provide some kind
of visualization
with the information.
So, what did we learn after this
summer is that that processing
that has to happen
with the 41 parts,
we need a lot more
interns and a lot of them.
So, I was actually very
excited to hear about the access
that the schools might
have, in terms of being able
to start looking at data sets.
But we also need a
better understanding
of the MARC records and the
cataloging language that is used
within the 651 fields.
And then, we're also looking
at the commercial
databases that are out there.
As I mentioned, Josh
would go to Amazon
and actually get
the jacket covers,
to be able to make the project
more appealing visually.
It isn't completely
necessary, but really figuring
out what databases exist,
because we're looking at it
from the geographic location
within the work of fiction.
But there are other databases
out there that we need
to incorporate their
information.
So, going back to that Illinois
Writers Project, there's a lot
of great data that they have
that would inform this
particular project.
So, trying to take a
look at the data sets
that already exist
within the field.
So, some of the ones that
we're looking at are Amazon,
Overdrive, GoodReads, which is
also Amazon, Barnes & Noble,
in terms of databases that
exist and what would be involved
with merging and
sharing that data?
So, some of the next
steps that we are taking,
we will have another junior
fellow here this summer,
and this junior fellow, most
likely, will come from --
will be a graduate student in
library information sciences.
We'd really love to get
into the cataloging aspect
to the project.
And again, mentioning,
we will be examining some
of the other databases,
and we'll start meeting
with other potential end users.
Again, we have the state
centers, which is one
of the driving forces for
this project, in particular.
But thinking about the students
that you work with and the folks
who would be able to
implement making their own map,
using the robust data
that we could provide.
And we're thinking,
at this juncture --
I'm not making any promises.
I'm not even asking permission,
but we're thinking
about crowdsourcing.
There's a project that was
done with the DC Public Library
that started in 2012, where
librarians were invited
into their database to
pull out passages of books
that took place in different
neighborhoods in Washington DC,
and they were able
to map that out.
It started in earnest in 2012.
I think it's not as updated
as it was in the beginning
of the project, but they
opened it up to library
and librarian professionals
to mark those records
for their needs.
And so, we're trying to take a
look at what does crowdsourcing
with this look like, and
what kind of information,
potentially, we could get back,
versus, again, the information
that becomes very
important for the library,
in terms of its cataloging
and cataloging records.
So, that's a little bit of what
we're looking at, but again,
for the educators in the
crowd, I want you to be aware
that we're really looking
at it from your perspective
and how you might be able to
use this with your students
and be able to really
visualize American literature.
So, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Tim St. Onge: All
right, thank you, Kathleen.
So, at this point, I'd like
to invite all our speakers
from this morning
up onto the stage.
What we'll do is we'll have
our speaker standing up here.
Any sort of questions you have,
you can field to
the whole group.
The only one thing we will be
doing is repeating the question
back into the microphone, so
that our video picks it up.
But aside from that, feel free
to ask any questions
of the folks up here.
We can have an open
discussion, so thank you.
>> Charlie Fitzpatrick:
And don't be shy.
Okay, we better have a pointer.
>> Female: I'll get it.
>> Female: Perfect.
>> Male : I'll start.
Hi. Some of you already
know me [speaking off mic].
Candice, I do direct this to
you, although I'd be happy
to hear from any of you.
With the work that you
been doing in schools,
with your GeoMentors, one
of the things that comes
to my mind is how GIS can also
bring students into science
and geography and things
that maybe they wouldn't
have thought before.
You address that a little bit
through the careers angle,
but I wonder if you're seeing
[speaking off mic] the role
that this can play
in diversifying geosciences
and geography?
>> Candice Luebbering:
Absolutely.
Do you want me to
repeat the question?
Okay, so the question, generally
speaking is how we're seeing GIS
as diversifying people coming
to the geospatial industry
and applications of it.
You saw the one tweet,
for example,
of working with the Girls'
Innovation Academy, right?
So, I guess there's two
ways I look at this in terms
of how it's improving the
diversity of use of GIS
and also the diversity
of users of GIS.
So, one, you know,
it's the challenge
and there's even discussion,
right, of the different levels
of spatial thinking
skills based on sex, right?
Girls, versus boys, and so, even
in the types of toys they use.
We heard that this morning.
So, when you bring
this into the classroom
and exposing everyone using
this spatial thinking,
I think there is
a great potential,
and there is a great potential
of having more females
interested in STEM fields
and using this technology
that maybe didn't have
access to it before.
And you do have people
going and working just
with Girl Scouts, right?
Just with Boy Scouts, with 4-H,
with people who maybe
didn't have access
in their typical
classrooms before.
But also, we're reaching
more students,
and people are getting more
understanding of different uses
of GIS, because it's
being used, again,
not just a geography classes,
because there are actually a lot
of those, unfortunately, right?
But it's being used
in history classrooms.
It's being used in
environmental science.
literature, as we've seen.
So, it's our way of
sneaking spatial thinking
and to all these topics.
It's already there.
Like it's already inherently
part of the discipline
in these topics, but you don't
think of may be, typically,
in a literature class, let's
do some online mapping.
What? Aren't we going
to just talk
about metaphors and symbology?
You know, or even in music
or history, even though it's
so spatially grounded
and located.
So, the idea that
technology just doesn't belong
in an engineering classroom,
and it doesn't just
belong is people interested
in a certain career
track, right?
We can use it in all
these different ways,
all these different subjects,
with all different
types of students.
So, I hope that addresses
your question.
But yes, we very much hope
that we're contributing to that
through this program and
through Esri's donation
and more students
simply getting involved
in this all different ways.
So, thanks.
>> Male: As a follow-up,
have you looked at that
at all systematically, in
terms of the populations
that you serve [inaudible].
>> Candice Luebbering: So, as
I mentioned in my presentation,
reporting from our volunteers
is really difficult to get.
Again, they're excited
to go do stuff,
but they don't often
tell us about it.
He'll tell us about
a year later,
and we don't push too
hard to systematically try
and plug our volunteers for
a lot of data and feedback,
because our focus is really
on them having the energy
and focusing on the
outreach component,
because it really is
an outreach program,
but I do see our community is
there is this great potential
to get involved with
them and learn from them
and get more information about
the engagements they've done.
We've done it more
with the case study.
So, about 40 of those that are
online where people are talking
about how many students
they work with
and what did or didn't work?
What was challenging
about the environment?
The constrictions of time
or curriculum or that kind
of thing, and feedback,
individual feedback
from students.
You know, stories, anecdotally,
of students who have taken off,
who have gone and gotten an
internship, or have said,
"I'm majoring in this now."
Or now they're working with
the county GIS department,
or something like that.
So, because it's been
an outreach program,
we haven't had that angle of it.
I'd love to, and I think
the potential is there,
because we have all
these volunteers to tap
that kind of information from.
But yeah, it's a great idea.
Yep.
>> Charlie Fitzpatrick: If
I can just add a little bit
to one of those points.
In the question about students'
engagement, there are a number
of students that
have been tempted
to leave school whose
parents have said
that my child is coming
to school because they get
to be a part of this class,
and they get to do GIS.
There are number of people
who have said this parent --
teachers have talked with me
and said this parent came up
and said this child
is staying in school,
in order to take this class.
Or this student now has
something to look forward to,
a way to feel good about school.
And so, there are a
number of students
who have been feeling success in
ways that they've not been able
to experience in
five or 10 years.
There are number
of students, also,
who are in various ways
special-needs students
who have found tremendous
success working with GIS.
So, there's a lot of ways
of thinking about how some
of these additional exposures
can influence people's lives.
[ Female Speaking off Mic ]
>> Charlie Fitzpatrick: So,
standards, models, how are we,
and I'll speak for Esri on
this, addressing the notion
of meeting standards,
helping people cope
with the ultimate flexible tool
and less flexible
educational environment?
The short answer is
we are a GIS company,
not an education company.
And so, as broadly applicable
as GIS is, as powerful as it is,
we said we can't possibly
meet, the 2-1/2 of us
on the K-12 team, can't
possibly meet the needs
of the 50 million students
across the country.
What we are trying to do is
to help educators recognize
that they can use tools in
a lot of different ways.
We have any number of situations
where a really good
teacher working with GIS
in this department is across
the hall from a teacher
in the same department
who will not use GIS
because the second teacher
says he or she needs to focus
on the standards, even though
the first teacher says I'm using
it to meet the standards.
And so, there are all kinds
of situations that we run
into where, you know, as the
Congressman was talking about.
Standards are important.
Standards are helpful.
That's why we have
said are many of them,
and it's always a
challenge to know
which ones you're going to meet.
There are a number of
people who say we can't look
at geo inquiries, if they
don't have our state --
we can even look at the document
if it doesn't have
our state on it.
If it has a national
standard, we can't use it.
We can't. So, it's
really a challenge
for the educational environment.
One of the biggest pieces
that we have started
to notice is a number of people
who are saying we're feeling
empowered to be creative
in the ways that
we meet standards,
because there is no
one way to meet them,
and GIS will adapt to do that.
[ Male Speaking off Mic ]
[ Female Speaking off Mic ]
You get to answer it.
>> Female: So, the question
was, and I'm going to repeat it
for everyone, was has the
library, as an enterprise.
I'm going to use that
term as an enterprise,
because I think it's
a lot easier
than to just say the
Geography and Map Division.
Has the library itself
made a commitment
to offering these type of
data sets and/or education
for the public?
Short answer is not yet.
Long answer is where
we want to be.
I think those of you,
especially, I know the two Mikes
and the Butch as John referred
to them earlier and the Bebes,
all know that we had to
build the architecture first,
and we talked a little bit
about the geospatial
hosting environment earlier.
The architecture had to
come first, but I think back
to the point, and I think that
both Candice and Charlie made,
and this is where I'm going
to tie it back to my speakers,
is a talked about giving
the software to people,
but giving the software
to people is not enough.
Candice talked about
GeoMentoring,
where you actually
have people coming in,
even if it's just being an
advocate for using the software
or exploring the possibilities
of what the software
can do for you.
I think Charlie talked
a little bit more
about a more systematic program,
where they actually
built lesson plans.
They got people excited
about doing these activities.
So, they wanted to go
onto the next phase,
the next phase, and
the next phase.
So, I think there's a lot of
planning before you can go
to that step, and I think
we'd love to be part of it.
I don't think we're
there right now.
>> Kathleen McGuigan:
And I'll put on my hat
in working with the teachers.
I would say that what we
try and do with our team is
to show the resources that the
library has in its collections
and look at some of
the educational uses
within those collections.
So, if an initiative comes
out from the library.
Just recently, as
a matter of fact,
I think it was October 24th,
was the crowds.loc.gov,
which is a crowdsourcing project
in looking at transcribing data
from the handwritten documents,
and actually laying that out.
And so, what we do is work with
educators throughout the country
and showing them the resource
itself, how they implement it,
and I think you got to that
really well, which is it's
up to the teachers to be able
to see the educational value.
We can't script it.
We can prescribe it, but we
do show them the resources
that are available to them.
And I want to go back to the one
question about standards, too,
and looking at the standards.
The American Association
of School Librarians just
released new informational
literacy standards, and it's up
to states whether to incorporate
that in different
curricula around the country,
but there are advocates
out there who are looking
at how you can look at
these types of literacy.
AASL is definitely a
thought partner in that.
National Science Teachers
Association is another partner.
They have the next-generation
science standards,
as well is ISTE is the
International Society
for Technology and Education.
So, there is that conversation.
Where the confluence of that
meets, it definitely comes
down to, in a lot of ways, comes
down to the individual states
and then rolling out
through the district.
So, I just wanted to throw
that in there, but we do work
with those groups,
too, and taking a look
at what those standards
are, so that we can add
that to our vocabulary,
in terms of working
with educators throughout
the country.
[ Male Speaking off Mic ]
>> Male: I actually just
want to offer a quick comment
on the standards issue.
Prior to coming to
Esri, I spent 15 years
as a [speaking off mic], and
you know, we worked nonstop
on the K-12 project,
and the thing to know
about it is geography is one
of nine core academic subjects
identified in the federal law
under the Elementary and
Secondary Education Act,
as the core subjects that
students should focus
on [speaking off mic].
But of course, we
live in a country
where state standards are set
at the state and local level,
and the federal government can
really only have an influence
by making the states
follow the money.
And even though geography
has always been a core
academic subject.
It never had any associated
funding authorization with it.
But that changed in 2015
when Congress passed the
Every Student Succeeds Act,
and President Obama
signed it into law.
For the first time, there
two dedicated authorizations
in federal K-12 law dealing
with geography education.
And so, hopefully, if Congress
redoes the K-12 law again,
and those authorizations are
strengthened [speaking off mic]
it's an opportunity for
geography to make more inroads
in what we're doing in K-12
instruction around the country.
So, you know, we need to tall
our local educators the stories
about what, you know, GIS can do
for students, for
spatial thinking.
And, you know, we need to also
work with folks, you know,
across the street here, so when
they do reauthorize a K-12 law
again, and it's supposed
to be potentially
considered next year.
They need to think about
the importance, you know,
what geography means in
workforce development.
So, it's a multipronged
approach,
and it's something that's
evolving and it's something
that can really make an
impact on [speaking off mic].
[ Female Speaking off Mic ]
>> I feel very blessed from
those asking these questions,
and I'm curious to know,
are there other GIS tools
that schools are using outside
of Esri that you've come
across in your work or
talking with educators,
the ones that you use?
I'm sorry.
I love Esri and ArcGIS Online.
I know you're the big player in
the field, and I'm just curious
to know what else is going
on out there outside of Esri.
>> Candice Luebbering: Sure.
So, obviously, we have a
great partnership with Esri,
and that uniform
software donation, really,
is the launching pad and what
most people use, but and Esri,
I believe, and Charlie
agrees, with the concept
of GeoMentor is bigger
than that, right?
It's about promoting
geography, spatial thinking,
and getting more students
on board and expose
that in any way, shape, or form.
So, we also do encourage
our volunteers
to use what they
know best, as well.
What maybe classrooms
are already using
and what there's interest in.
So, it can be open source.
It can be QGIS.
So many apps, of
course, as well.
So Mapilary.
You know, and people are using
Map Box products and Leaflet.
I mean, we encourage anything
and everything, because it's all
about getting kids
mapping, right?
It's getting kids
thinking spatially.
And so, we're not
just promoting ArcGIS.
We're promoting the
bigger concept
and Esri's very forward
thinking and thinking that, too.
So, yeah, definitely.
There are a lot of other
things being implemented.
>> Charlie Fitzpatrick:
I'll jump in on that also,
just to say that the questions
that we get from people are --
there are people on the
Macintosh platform who want
to do desktop GIS, and that's
not doable with Esri technology,
except under virtualization.
And so, there are a number
of people that we have seen,
a number, less than 10 schools
that have talked with me
about can they integrate
stuff that they do with QGIS?
There are a number of people who
are working with Google as a way
of getting started,
and we're comfortable
with whatever it is
people want to do.
What we generally, as
Candice was mentioning,
what we generally find
that people are looking
for is a package of resources
and a variety of opportunities.
And so, given that people have
access to, in a school bundle,
ArcGIS Online, Community
Analyst, ArcGIS Desktop,
ArcMap, the suite of apps.
Survey 1-2-3 and Collector are
the most commonly used ones,
but additional kinds of apps
with the ArcGIS environment,
and they can do it for free, has
been sufficient for most people.
[ Female Speaking off Mic ]
>> Kathy Hart: Yeah, so, in
higher education, they're coming
in with sometimes little and
sometimes more experience.
I think the higher education
market is pretty well entrenched
with Esri, but there's
a lot of people
in the higher education arena
that are doing a lot of coding.
And so, they're doing
modifications
and all sorts of things.
So, there's a lot of
Esri in higher ed,
but there's other open source
apps being developed, as well.
So...
[ Female Speaking off Mic ]
So, okay, so there's a lot
of A. There's a lot of arts.
There's a lot of
humanities that are working
with geospatial technologies.
A large, large swath of scholars
in the humanities, history,
archaeology, literature that
are using GIS, either Esri
or any other resource, to really
understand their topic better.
So, there's definitely
the STEAM,
the humanities, everything.
There's a lot going on.
So, I encourage everyone
to think broadly.
Today, we were talking STEM.
That's kind of how
it was presented,
but there's definitely a
lot of other topics, so...
>> Kathleen McGuigan: I was
just going to say, I mean,
one of the things we've
always been looking at it
from the STEAM perspective here
at the Library of Congress,
but one of the things
that I keep hearing now
is the digital humanities.
And it seems to be that is what
the field is moving towards,
at least in the K-12.
I mean STEM, STEM, STEM has been
out there for a very long time,
and then STEAM came
in, you know,
at least from the K-12 area.
And now, you hear a lot
about the digital humanities,
and you're absolutely right.
DC has a lot of codewords, yeah.
>> Charlie Fitzpatrick: And
I'll add to that that one
of the things that happened is
with the rise of story maps,
we had, prior to that point,
we had a hard time
getting English teachers,
in particular, engaged with GIS.
But as soon as story
maps came out,
English teacher started
paying attention
and asking us questions, and
what was happening even more is
that the science and the social
studies teachers were saying,
my God.
Our kids really need to have
better communication skills.
How do we engage that?
Who do we turn to?
I was like, hello, have
you met your neighbors?
Getting people to engage with
others in the disciplines.
This is where we really try
to get people to recognize
that with GIS, you're going
to be covering everything,
and so, you know, embrace it.
Enjoy it, and do it
all day every day.
>> Female: Anything else?
>> Tim St. Onge: All right,
how about a round of applause
for our speakers today?
[ Applause ]
Thank you so much to
our speakers today,
including Congressman
Bruce Westerman,
our keynote this morning.
But again, we've had
such a nice collection
of talks this morning.
I hope you all enjoyed it,
talking about GIS in education
and here the Library of Congress
and in other institutions.
So, just a couple things to
wrap up our morning session.
First off, coming off of
what Charlie had mentioned
about story maps.
So, the Library of Congress,
if you have not heard yet,
has been making our own
story maps for little while.
So, that sort of represents
one of our frontward --
currently frontward-facing
applications of GIS technology
and getting into
web applications.
So, in case you haven't
heard of it before and want
to check them out, if you
go to LOC.gov/storymaps,
we have about seven or
eight published so far,
and this represents
different projects
that have been implemented
from subject matter experts
from across the library.
So, Prints and Photographs
Division, Geography
and Map Division, and
plenty of other divisions
across the library that are
showcasing different collections
of the library and
using interactive maps
to tell that story.
So, not only do you have the
interactive maps that sort
of dive you into the data
surrounding that collection,
but there are also collection
items like photos and maps
that -- or static maps that
illustrate those collections,
and they really bring
them to life.
So, I think that they're really,
really fascinating items,
and you should definitely
check them out.
It's LOC.gov/storymaps.
And so, aside from that, thank
you very much for coming.
We really appreciate you
guys joining us this morning
and learning about GIS and sort
of celebrating GIS Day with us.
So, thank you very much.
[ Applause ]